with Rambo last Blood Sylvester Stalone
hopes to put an exclamation mark at the
end of the five film series that is John
Rambo story last Blood follows Rambo
struggle to get his niece Gabrielle back
from a Mexican cartel after they abduct
her for a human trafficking ring viewers
know to expect a bloody confrontation
but that doesn't mean the ending is
entirely predictable with that in mind
let's dig into the end of Rambo last
blood warning spoilers ahead John Rambo
began his cinematic journey in first
blood as a man II was just trying to
find a way to move on in a country that
didn't seem to have a place for him
anymore
in the for film since then Rambo was
battled with himself to quell a
warrior's rage while also shooting lots
of people peace just doesn't seem to be
an option for Rambo Stallone said in an
interview with variety you can totally
end the story with him going home
having that shot of him going down the
driveway which is completion but a
character like that does he ever really
go home I just sit down on a post if he
came home but he never arrived
and I went there's a movie here the
warrior could never find peace
he just can't that sense of never truly
feeling at peace physically manifests
and last blood as a tunnel's Rambo digs
it's also encapsulated in something he
tells Gabrielle early on he never
changed he just learned to keep a lid on
it through the ultraviolent ending of
the film we see that the lid wasn't on
too tight a hallmark of the Rambo
franchise has always been the appearance
of a somewhat hopeful figure in John
Rambo's life right when he's at his most
hopeless that was his mentor Colonel
Trautman in the first film and in recent
films it's taken the form of a woman
hoping to convince Rambo to move on with
his life in las blood that's common a
journalist covering mexican cartels who
lost her sister to the human trafficking
machine
Carmen cleans John up when the Martinez
brothers beat and scar him then helps
him find the right connections to exact
vengeance later with Ramos quest for
blood finished what happens to Carmen
there's no way she wouldn't hear about
his one-man defeat of the Martinez
cartel and all of their enforcers and
it's hard to imagine she'd just be a
bystander
after forming a bond with Rambo it's
quite possible that the aftermath of the
film creates an opportunity for her to
step in and tell the world the story of
what happened that day on the Rambo
family ranch
Rambo's blood relatives have all died
since he returned to America but he does
have a chosen family his niece Gabrielle
and her grandmother Maria who looks
after the Rambo family estate and takes
care of Gabrielle
the tragic loss of Gabrielle to a cartel
driven drug overdose is the emotional
linchpin of las blood and drives rambo
to action before that happens though
Maria leaves her rambo family runs
behind taking her memories of gabrielle
with her so what happens to Maria it
seems likely that she's a last living
person in Rambo would leave any kind of
inheritance to which would place her at
the center of his story as the public
learns of his war at the cartel but it's
unclear whether she'll choose to return
rumble as blood is a human story about a
man who feels there's nothing he can do
but fight something half of this
traumatic he's pushed but it's also a
story in which a couple dozen members of
a Mexican cartel come to Arizona with
assault rifles to kill a guy who just
happened to have enough firepower to
bring them all down and blow up half his
property while is that it yes it's a
Rambo movie but it still exists in a
version of our world so there are bound
to be some political implications
stemming from Rambo's last stand against
a cartel
at one point we see cartel members
showing up to a crime scene and walking
right through the police with their guns
drawn these guys can seemingly do
whatever they want with impunity after
the battle in Arizona the cartels might
not go away but a greater public focus
on human trafficking could lead to some
kind of crackdown likely at the border
so what actually happens to John Rambo
as the film ends Rambo is just when his
battle with the cartel literally cutting
out Hugo Martinez his heart he stumbles
onto his paws to sit in a rocking chair
and nurse a gunshot wound in his abdomen
as he does the camera zooms out and we
see the chair is still rocking as a
credits roll to your life Rambo's ending
monologue about cherishing the memories
of those he's lost is followed by a
credit montage of moments from all four
previous films this culminates in a
wounded bloody Rambo climbing on a horse
and riding away from the ranch but the
film made a point of showing us that
Rambo drove his horses away from the
barn to protect them from the cartel
that this horse wander back or is that
Rambo's passage into the next life in
the form of a ride into the sunset it's
certainly up for interpretation from
first blood on the overarching narrative
of the Rambo series is violence for
guessing violence Rambo it's a warrior
because he's good at it and he was
trained to be but he doesn't start the
fight they drew first blood not me he's
pushed to the edge and then he pushes
back then the cycle continues even as he
tries to keep a lid on it in last Bloods
this sense of being pushed too far
culminates in his explanation that he
could never stop as long as innocent
people are being
and there's an undercurrent of hope at
the end of last blood though as Rambo's
parting words to the audience meditate
on memory and loss he doesn't want other
people to be like him he doesn't want
people to get hurt and suffer
senselessly he just knows he has
something inside him that will react
when injustice does happen though by the
end of the film he seems to have found a
way to make peace with that food memory
if he can draw last blood maybe it will
finally be enough check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]